good morning John it's Friday I'm
sitting here in my usual spot but with
an unusual camera this is a VidCon 2010
flip camera there were like 10 or 20 of
these made I actually did the design on
the front of the camera thank you very
much to barry car who got this flip cam
at VidCon 2010 and gave it to me as a
present
in celebration of 10 years of VidCon
it's like taking pictures of the
polaroid camera it really feels like of
another era for example I love that John
among the many things that of course
happened at VidCon the most important
the thing everybody wants to see is yes
I crushed the gush a while back I
uploaded a video on vlogbrothers that
was meant for Hanks channel it was like
4 minutes and 2 seconds long so I had to
get punished and the punishment I
settled on because of a weird thing that
I have with gushers is that I would
drink the gush juice turns out there's
not a lot of juice per gusher so I
needed help and I got it in the form of
these nice people who squeezed gushers
into cups for most of the live episode
of dear Hank and John that we did on the
stage at VidCon and then
[Applause]
so right there right that moment
something interesting happened inside of
my mouth I knew that it was gonna be
very sweet but I didn't know that it's
gonna be extremely sour like it's both
but it it's very sour sensation is kind
of a wait because it's it's kind of
heavy and it doesn't like move around
like water does so it's sort of like
slap into my tongue
the second sensation was my salivary
glands responding to the sourness of it
and immediately releasing the maximum
amount of saliva that they could you got
if you got a small rat but does that
count if you don't swallow it just get
it down oh it was like Jacuzzi Jets of
saliva it was helpful though because it
would have been very difficult to
swallow with the gush because it's so
thick without all that I had had liquid
I was actually swallowing was like spit
gush and then I went back I don't know
cuz I was on stage and like people had
worked really hard to squeeze all this
gush out of gushers for a second helping
questionable
uh yeah and then like a piece fell off
the top of the gush cup into my glasses
which made me panic a little bit so I
knew that drinking the gush was gonna be
bad
but I did not realize that having drunk
the gush was going to be worse partially
because my stomach was just very upset
extremely acidic I would love to know
the pH of gush juice crash came quickly
and and lasted for the rest of the day
and of course to my crew of lovely gush
milkers you're the best thank you for
your support additional things that are
happening one John and I are going on a
very short tour in Madison Wisconsin in
Minneapolis Minnesota I'm gonna be live
podcasts me and Katherine are gonna do
one John and it's gonna do Anthropocene
reviewed and we're gonna do a live dear
Hank and John we're calling it a minute
tour because it's a mini tour and also
because Steve the Minotaur will be
giving a short lectures more expensive
tickets for people who want to meet us
afterward and all the money we make is
gonna go to support our communities work
improving maternal health in Sierra
Leone also scishow just released its
first documentary film it's discussing
whether Apollo was actually a good idea
in celebration of Apollo's 50th
anniversary and to celebrate that we've
got a mission patch and we're also doing
a new pin every month celebrating a
different space mission we're starting
off celebrating Apollo's two different
colors they're standard and go in the
dark they're the same price that's all
the things can't wait to see people next
month in Minneapolis and Madison John
I'll see you on Tuesday
there's gusher oh my glasses oh my god
it's like still dripping off
I guess these are the mouths gushers oh
that's so horrible